Emily you made a film a few years back
with some of your friends Y what did you
learn from the experience oh uh there
are so many lessons uh that I took away
from the experience of making like the
water there were a couple of things that
were really clear to me so we made the
film at this sort of watershed moment in
the industry which was when we started
um uh sort of telling people about the
movie um and when we finished shooting
which by by the way was from February
2011 to August
2011 uh so I learned don't try to make a
feature just from idea to finish in
eight months that's one of the things I
learned um but from that period of of
2011 the way that you could write a
business plan fundamentally changed so
um it wasn't just that we learned that
oh I don't know if you're making uh an
independent drama starring all women
with no sex and no relationships nobody
will fund that movie that's one of the
things that I learned um another thing
that I learned was that um the business
was going to change really rapidly for a
while um so when we started you could
write things about in your business plan
about potential theatrical releases and
the Distributors who might pick you up
at which kinds of festivals and by the
end of the time we had finished shooting
new things had popped up like Ultra VOD
releases and day and date had become uh
a much bigger part of the discussion and
no theatrical release at all direct to
Consumer was becoming more and more
popular BEC me partially out of
necessity um and then in the time
subsequent to that while we were
finishing the film and thinking about
going on the festival circuit is when I
would learn um number one just how
difficult it is if you're waiting to be
picked out of the crowd by the big
festival or by the big distributor to be
part of the
0.004% for whom that happens right
that's one thing and I'm totally willing
to assume that I might be in the 99.96%
OR
96% um and so we needed to build better
business models in order to get our
films made if we wanted to continue
making them as something other than a
hobby so that that was really like the
whole whole process just served to teach
me that the business is in this huge
transition in this I mean at that moment
and continues to be in transition and
will continue to be in transition for
some time um and so uncertainty was
going to be you know tumultuous
uncertainty was going to be kind of the
steady state of the business for the
next foreseeable
future at what point did you say I'm not
in the mood to make another film knowing
how things are knowing some of the
battles that I might face with the next
one but I have another idea um
in so we finished shooting like the
water in August of
2011 and we went immediately into post
um I wish actually we had taken a little
bit of a breather and kind of you know
checked back in with because the editing
process you always get lost in the
forest for the trees and while the
director was in the editing room and she
was quite lost in the forest for the
trees I was out trying to figure out
what were the next steps for the film um
I went to AFM for the first time which
is my least favorite place on the planet
um and uh I'm going to get in trouble
for saying that but whatever um but uh
sometime around when I started learning
about how uh you have a film you get it
into a festival usually because a sales
agent has helped you or you know the
sales agent picks you up at the festival
and the sales agent helps you sell it to
a distributor and the distributor helps
you package it and uh well actually
spends your money to um package it for
the exhibitor and Market it to an
audience and then the exhibitor collects
the money that your audience spends on
your movie and they take a cut and the
distributor takes a cut plus everything
that they spent to do all that stuff and
then the sales agent takes a cut and by
the time it gets back to you there's no
money left none I mean I have friends
who had films get picked up at Sundance
by the distrib comp that you hope to get
picked up by and they made Z on it and I
was like well that's not sustainable
like for whom is that sustainable um so
that was really the point that I thought
well there's an interesting thing that
happened when we made like the water
which was we knew because we weren't
going to get traditional financing that
we had to reach out to our community and
we reached out to them with a clear
story and the first part of that story
was here is why we think we need to make
this movie now um and what it means to
us personally to do this and two
actually three things to what we think
it might mean to Women filmmakers to
Women in general to um to the
representation better representation in
film and then the third piece was and
here is every specific thing we need to
make this movie and what happened was
when we went out with this list we call
it the original wish list um which was
just a a list that we typed into our
WordPress website we put a little PayPal
Link in the bottom um when people could
see exactly what their contribution to
the film was the car rental the
sunscreen the bug spray which was really
important if you're shooting in Maine in
the summer get bug spray
um people tended to contribute more than
we had thought and then they started
loaning us stuff we hadn't considered
and they started loaning Us locations
and goods goods and services that we
didn't think we could get and they took
our tiny little you know $85,000 movie
and made it look much bigger and much
fancer I mean we we look for the
locations that were loan to us like a $5
million movie and those were all loan to
us it made our film better because we
had this early interaction with our
audience and then as we continued into
the festival circuit no matter where our
film screened anywhere in the world and
I'm I'm including Waka and Romania and
Memphis was it Memphis Tennessee no
somewhere in Mississippi and obviously
in Maine where we shot it somebody who
contributed to that campaign or somebody
who knew somebody who did showed up and
when we did screenings for our community
we had lines down the block and around
the corner we could sell out a 350 seat
theater and this is for a tiny
independent drama about grief starring
only women mostly unknown actors right
and so at that moment when I saw kind of
the the wreckage of the business model
that Indie filmmakers even in the best
case scenario were being promised and
this incredible investment from the
audience that was created out of this
wishlist model um and this was at the
end of 2011 I was like maybe we could
maybe there's something in there and
that's when I really started exploring
it and it was another sort of six months
until it was fully ideated um as this uh
sort of One-Stop shop crowdfunding and
distribution and obviously ly in the
last two years we have iterated on the
idea quite a bit because we've gotten so
much feedback from the community and
they've been so incredibly vocal about
no this is the next thing we need and
we're like okay we'll try to get you
that you
know when it comes to crowdfunding where
do you see most filmmakers
failing okay it's way easier to fail at
a crowdfunding campaign that it is to
succeed and um I think we are finally
moving away away from this idea that if
you build it they will come um a
crowdfunding platform is not going to
make you succeed so we have the highest
success rate in the business we have a
near 80% campaign success rate and
that's because we spend um several
stages of uh feedback with our
filmmakers before we say yes we think
you're ready to crowdfund um just like
making a film your crowdfunding campaign
generally speaking is one or lost in the
pre-production and then your ability to
execute on the plan you put together in
the pre-production um the other thing is
that the word crowdfunding is a compound
word there are two words in that word
and the first word is not there because
it's a prettier word it's there because
it's the more important word you cannot
get funding if you do not already have
the crowd so filmmakers often make the
mistake and actually people in general
in crowdfunding make the the mistake
that your crowdfunding is where you do
your audience building no crowdfunding
is a phase and it's not the first phase
of audience building that you are doing
throughout your entire career right um
so you have to be able to prove through
message testing which is something that
we teach basically interacting with your
crowd a lot to figure out what they like
and what they don't like you have to
prove to yourself that you can get total
strangers to click on the stuff that you
are off offering before you should ever
launch a crowdfunding campaign otherwise
you're going to stay inside just your
friends and family right so I think a
common misperception is that oh it's the
crowdfunding platform's job to find the
non-friends and family and I can tell
you that landing on the homepage of even
the biggest crowdfunding uh
platforms on average filmmakers see only
a 4% bump in their um and this is true
for us as well like landing on the
homepage does doesn't get you a
ginormous bump in strangers you get
yourself to your audience and the I
think the Primacy of the platform is
actually kind of problematic in so far
as you know they think oh if I go on one
of the big platforms that's where all
the strangers will find me no you have
to find the strangers and tell them
where you are um that's actually how
crowdfunding really succeeds and the way
that you do that is you get really
really specific about who your audience
is where they hang out and how they like
to be talked to and therefore how you
reach
them let's go back to this like Field of
Dreams type if the biggest lie that was
ever told us yeah okay so there seems to
be this prevailing myth that exists that
filmm filmmakers excuse me can build an
audience using social media and make a
living where though does this audience
come from if they don't even have a film
yet you know they say well get that
audience going then start making your
film include them in the process but at
this point there's so many people doing
it do you think that
that's real do you think people can
really I mean not everybody's Kevin
Smith not everybody's Louis CK who can
just put up a PayPal thing and get
donations let's be really clear about
the Louis CK correlation Louis C is an
overnight sensation 20 years in the
making Louis CK decided he didn't want
anybody to intermediate his career and
therefore from the very beginning he was
building a direct relationship with his
audience right his ability to now sell
out of his own website came from a
20-year dedication and he turned down
money that he could have taken when he
could have taken a deal where sort of
somebody else was responsible for the
audience and kept his career smaller for
a while because he wanted the direct
relationship he wanted to own the
pipeline the whole time that takes a
tremendous amount of integrity and hard
work and um and a real desire for
Independence and the fact is like not
everybody actually wants an independent
career I would just like us to stop
treating independent filmmaking as the
calling card to the studio system I
don't think that's what it is cuz that's
not independent if you want to build an
independent career you absolutely have
to dedicate yourself to actively
engaging your audience who is your
audience well um I like to start here
right we do this in the class that we
teach all over the country which is we
ask someone in the audience to give us
the um the logline and short synopsis of
the film that they're thinking of
crowdfunding and they give the brief
synopsis and I look around to the crowd
and I say who else in here would be
interested in seeing that and without
fail 10 hands go up and those people
don't look the same they don't belong to
the same
demographic um and I say okay now I want
you to ask these people where do you
hang out on online what times of day are
you online on those platforms what kind
of news do you do you look at um what
kind of music do you listen to what kind
of um blogs do you read if any blogs
what do you do in your free time do you
belong to any organizations any alumni
groups where' you go to school what
makes you click when you click and most
importantly where do you watch stuff
when you watch it so the information
that you start to gather there lets you
get really specific about how to spend
your en energy because where do you get
most of your um recommendations for film
from your friends right so you always
start with the core group of people who
are actively interested in seeking out
new content that are actively interested
in seeking out the kinds of things that
you're making and you turn them into
amplifiers over time but it starts by
joining the conversation and you know
what it might mean we can't make
meaningless driil anymore it might mean
that we actually have to make stuff that
like busts through the doors and says I
have arrived do you know what I mean
like all of this year's breakout
performance films at the Gotham Awards I
think all of them were
crowdfunded and it felt like love and
dear white people and um uh uh a girl
walks home alone at night those are
movies that literally kicked the doors
open and said I am here and you have
never seen anything like me
so I I just I think it has to come from
um a deep desire for
Independence hard work and patience and
there's a video that's been circulating
that some big comedians like Reggie wats
and stuff got involved with that said
they want a no funding platform called
work harder and I actually well it was
very funny um it really misunderstands
what it takes to successfully crowdfund
and let me be clear if you are a film
artist you are always crowdfunding all
of your funding no matter whether it's
people buying tickets at the box office
or downloading your movie or giving you
25 bucks to get your film off the ground
in the earlier stages it's all
crowdfunding and it all takes the same
tools of identifying that audience
activating them getting them excited
getting them to tell their friends at
every stage of your film career so
crowdfunding has uh you know popped up
as this word of the thing that we've
needed to be doing all along right we've
just figured out a way to pull um to
actually make money marketing our films
before we've even made
them I was in the store the other day
and I literally heard this conversation
a woman was talking to her friend and
she said I just need to get on blank
which was a crowdfunding platform and
find all these rich people that want to
donate to these indie films I know
they're there and they're waiting and I
was like wow this is so good and I was
trying to listen to more and then they
passed by and I couldn't hear anything
more but I see that idea out there and I
see hashtags support indie film and
that's great but that's a bunch of Indie
filmmakers that were they're all seeing
that hashtag so who are those people
waiting to donate to these campaigns are
they people that are interested in a
niche that the film is about if the film
is about a group of women let's say
where there's no relationships no sex
but they're all maybe friends and
they're struggling with their own issues
is that the demographic for that film or
is it a bunch of people that have all
this disposable income that just can't
wait to Hash support indie
film
um I don't think there are that many
people out there desperately waiting to
throw their money at indie film um the
people of means who I know who
contribute to indie film do it in a very
savvy way as investors and if you are
going to approach an investor right
which is different from approaching a
crowdfunding audience if you're going to
approach an investor with a plan for
success as a reason why they should give
you a bunch of their disposable income
you have to show them demonstrably that
you can make money on the film The only
way that you can ever demonstrably show
that you can make money on a film is by
proving that you have access to the
audience that wants to see this film if
your business plan says I'm going to go
to a big Festival that I haven't gotten
into yet and get picked up by a
distributor for whom you know that who
picks up one or two titles out of
festivals a year and that's my path to
access to
audience most Savvy independent film
investors at this point are saying give
me a break um so the whole conversation
has shifted you can't even I mean sure
you could present present that you know
I'm going to go to a big festival and
I'm going to get picked up by a big
distributor business plan uh to people
who've never invested in film before and
um you can tell them a lie that you're
going to make money this way um or you
can do the work to build the audience
tell them the truth and make sure that
when they invest in this film they make
their money back so they invest in your
next film like the thing about
crowdfunding and about Gathering
investment for film in general is that
we all have a responsibility to one
another we have a responsibility to do
successful crowdfunding campaigns so
that everybody who touches crowdfunding
has a great experience we have a
responsibility to pay our investors back
so those investors will not only invest
in our films but other people's films um
I think we're you know too long we have
been like oh I'm I just need to hit
people in their pocketbooks no you have
to hit them in their hearts that's
that's why most independent film
investors invest actually um even the
ones who make money regularly invest
because it really touches them and moves
them um and certainly crowdfunding uh
campaigns are won and lost by reaching
the people who give a can I say
that sure great um crowdfunding
campaigns are won and lost by reaching
the people who give a about what
you are talking about you know they're
and they're segmented right there's the
people who give a that uh a group
of women are making a movie together
right because they care about women in
media there's a there's the segment of
people who feel like um you know women's
friendships are not accurately
represented on screen and that's why
they might have contributed to like the
water and then there's the group of
people who um are really interested in
you know delving into stories about
grief those are harder people to reach
like this is why raising money for drama
is difficult in the first place cuz like
getting people to out themselves about
difficult subject matter matter can be
complicated but um it's not like your
audience has one quality or can be
spoken to in one way or can be reached
on a single platform and that's why it
is on you as the producer or the
whatever film making team you have to
know enough about your
audiences and their proclivities in
order to reach them so there's no
platform that's going to do this work
for you because they can't they
fundamentally can't there's no platform
that has the resources to do all the
research that it takes and fundamentally
that audience should belong to you not
just for a single film but for your next
film and the one after and the one after
so for like the water how did you build
that audience because it was 2011 oh so
boy if I knew then what I know now how I
would have done everything differently
um we largely for like the water relied
upon the strength of our personal
networks but we had six women pushing
this Campa campaign not on a
crowdfunding site um we had six women
out there telling the story about what
it would take us to make this film and
why we deeply wanted to do it and the
fortunate thing is that with six women
um we were reaching into six different
cities the seven and then a seventh
which is New York and an eighth which
was Los Angeles because that's sort of
where our networks were um and we were
telling this story really passionately
and really concisely and we knew nothing
about crowdfunding like we were
literally making it up as we went along
but the wish list really helped us
articulate um this is not about you
giving us money this is about the
community coming together to sort of
acquire the stuff that it will take to
bring this story to life and what
happened well those people ended up also
being our um our extras and as we moved
into the small town where we were
shooting we got a local car dealership
involved and a coffee shop involved and
the fire department involved and the
police department involved and the I
mean all of these Community um folks
sort of rallied around it because we had
a really clear way to articulate our
story and we took a lot of lessons away
from that and built them into seedan
spark but I can't I can't lie and say
this was foresight right that like the
things that I'm telling you now are all
things that I learned by doing and
failing or not failing um along the way
I guess not failing would be succeeding
along the way I can see how the however
many women six seven eight nine women
would all have their own quote Network
and friends and family and then going to
this small town and people become very
invested in you and your project let's
take a filmmaker that lives in a big
city yeah and they're starting from
scratch and they've got this great idea
and they're going to launch a Twitter
and it's going to be about the film what
are they tweeting about because the film
hasn't even been made yet so the cool
thing about um what we call message test
which is kind of building the
relationship with your audience and
learning how they like to be spoken to
is that you can start with all of the
stuff that you do anyway you're reading
articles for inspiration you're doing
research you're finding photos you're
finding reference materials and you can
start to and you're also looking I mean
certainly in documentary you're like
looking for people to talk to as part of
your research um in uh in narrative you
might be going out and researching
certain situations or you know I don't
know going to a coffee shop and watching
people or whatever um I think dear white
people is a great example Justin wanted
to learn about the voice of this main
character and how people would react to
this voice of this radio dis jockey uh
who uh who has a show called dear white
people so he started the dear white
people Twitter handle and he started
tweeting things that he thought she
might say and that helped actually
structure his screenplay right and so it
was part of his his own internal
research that he was
externalizing um and people I mean it it
was a huge it was a sensation right um
and so I think you take the things that
are already happening as a part of your
world of inspiration and you are sharing
it with the community and you're asking
people about it you might be asking
specific people this is the beauty of
Twitter is you can kind of get to anyone
and you can go out and ask specific
people specific questions along the way
and you see filmmakers who are really
good at building audiences Ed Burns
while he's writing he's communicating
with his Twitter followers like what
should I name this character and you're
getting people invested in the
storytelling all along it always starts
with your own personal Network and I
have to be honest if you're going to be
an independent filmmaker you better be a
nice helpful collaborative person you
have to build your Social Capital to
live in this world it's very very
difficult to make an independent film
entirely by yourself and generally
speaking the best ones come from really
awesome bold collaborations at least
that has been my experience so
um the the way that you are in the world
is part of this go out and meet people
at places um talk about the things that
you're doing and the things that you're
thinking about volunteer on a couple of
your friends sets build some
relationships offer to do social media
on your on your friend set so you're
helping them build their audience
altruism is a tremendous way to build a
following if you just started a Twitter
account that was entirely dedicated to
recommending films that you thought were
really excellent to people you thought
might really like them you will
immediately gather a following and that
might be something you like to do
authenticity is a really important piece
of this if you're not a smiley face
happy exclamation pointy person don't be
that person on social media because
you'll hate yourself and you'll stop
doing it right find your Niche my friend
Caitlyn was saying the other day
um you know Twitter just doesn't do it
for her she can't quite that's not she's
not uh she is a Wordsmith actually she's
a brilliant writer but not in 140
characters she feels very limited but
she loves taking photographs so
Instagram has been the place where she's
really like found her kind of social
media tone and she feels comfortable
with that level of interaction and she
learns a lot about what people like and
don't like along the way and that I know
affects her as an artist as she develops
you know her next script um did that
answer your
question it did we threw the name Ed
Burns in there which I think gets put in
all the time and that's nothing against
him he's brilant filmmaker but not
everybody's Ed Burns you know I get that
sure I think it's important to look at
people who are good at it and you can't
point out it there are lots of famous
people who do do not have a rabid
following like Ed Burns and that the
difference is Ed Burns is good at
Twitter and they are not there are
plenty of famous people who have
attempted and failed at crowdfunding
because they don't understand that they
have to have a relationship with their
audience that matters Spike Lee's
campaign almost did not succeed at first
because his initial crowdfunding pitch
was lousy and ignored what it would take
to get his f fans who he had been
interacting with for a long time to
convert to crowdfunding supporters he
didn't understand what it took he
altered his pitch video partway through
his campaign and that's when it really
stepped up and succeeded right he got
schooled by his fans on crowdfunding
right and I think that's really
important is that the crowd is going to
make you a more attented attentive
empathic artist ultimately because
you're expanding the empathic space for
inspiration
you know you never know what tweet might
come at you what offer might come to you
um that will change the course of your
script I mean for like the water anyway
it
was these spaces that were new ways to
describe our story that we rewrote the
script to accommodate um and so if you
don't like the Ed burs example then I
will go back to the Justin Simeon dear
white people example like he was not
famous to start he just had a really
funny engaging Twitter account that was
based on him wanting to
inspire uh
himself right and seeking inspiration
from the audience I'll tell you what I
hate it when I have to have the
conversation with uh filmmakers or
artists in general who were like but
that's pandering to the audience and the
problem that I have with that statement
on its face is that if you think you can
Pander to an audience that that means
you think your audience is
stupid and The Logical extension of that
is if your audience is stupid then your
movies are stupid right stupid audiences
would like a stupid movie right so I
think it behooves us all to assume that
our audiences the ones that we're
seeking the ones that we're building the
ones that we're interacted interacting
with are at least as smart as we think
we
are biggest mistake you see in
crowdfunding Pitch
videos oh oh god um I'm going to make a
whole like blooper re of the worst
things you see in crowdfunding Pitch
videos cuz it's so common it's actually
really comical I don't know who wrote
the handbook and disseminated it behind
my back that says the first thing that
happens in a crowdfunding pitch video is
you should sit in front of the camera
and talk at people like we we are in a a
visual medium and we're always told in
our scripts and in our films to show not
tell and then we do a crowdfunding pitch
video and all we do is tell so here's my
my favorite um crowdfunding Pitch video
blooper right hi my name is Emily best
I'm actually do it this way hi my name
is Emily best and if this were really
one I would have bad sound right now so
lousy sound uh hi my name is Emily best
I'm the writer director lead actor and
producer of danger in Downtown LA um
danger in Downtown LA is a terrifying
Thriller starring me a woman that's like
not totally typical and um we have this
incredible script and this amazing cast
of people who you will meet and talk to
in a minute um but in I really want you
to get a sense of like what the film is
going to feel like so here's our
cinematographer who's going to talk to
you about why this is going to be a good
film um and then you're going to talk to
the cinematographer for a little bit and
then you'll talk to a couple of the
actors and then you'll come back and
they'll be like so um you know we're
totally broke you know indie film making
we don't have any money um we really
need your money that's the most
important thing that we could ask of you
um so donate
now and thanks bye we're going to make a
really scary film for you um I've seen
that video we've all seen this video and
they're like I don't I think it's good
I'm like by what standard if your movie
is okay I have so many things to say
about it first if we if you put nothing
else on the internet put this on the
internet do not ask for help with a
donation because by and large unless you
are backed by a 501c3 asking for a
donation is factually incorrect right
the tone of your campaign should be
asking someone to join what you are
offering with a contribution that means
you are making a contribution and they
are making a contribution and together
you're going to make something
magnificent okay that tone has to
permeate everything in your crowdfunding
campaign I am offering you such a
kick-ass opportunity to join this thing
that's going to be so exciting strap on
your seat bels this rocket is taking off
let's do this together like you be the
fuel I'll be the rocket and you be the
fuel right that's kind of what we're
talking about so the first thing is if
you are going to make a film let's say
called danger in Downtown LA I don't
know if that film exists but I'm making
one up for these purposes
um for no money at all you could take
this lovely Canon 5D or even your iPhone
and make it feel found footy and now
this neighborhood gets very dark at
night and the lighting is very weird and
now I'm over the shoulder of a woman I
can tell because her breathing is deep
and we're walking down in its a Alleyway
and it's kind of unsteady and you hear
something and it seems like maybe
somebody's just run behind you and you
turn around and there's nothing there
and then you turn back and uh the uh the
music kind of comes in you can find tons
of free creepy music out there if you
have a friend with a keyboard they can
create something for you and then all of
a sudden there's a crash and a smash and
the woman and the camera are down on the
ground and the breathing is heavy and
you don't know what happens
and hi my name is Emily best uh that was
the first little snippet of danger in
Downtown LA we have an incredible uh
cast and crew lined up I want to show
you first what our cinematographer is
capable of and then you spend you know
12 or 15 seconds with all of the cool
other stuff that your cinematographer
has done and maybe a cut of a few things
that your actors have been in if you
don't have time to shoot something sort
of native um there is the the whole
point is that if you're going to make a
small movie a pitch video 90 seconds
usually about why somebody should get
involved with this much longer movie
you're proposing to make your small
movie has to be good and in the tone and
demonstrate that you are capable of
making the thing that you are promising
on the long run and if you can't make a
90-second video basically for free that
gets people super excited maybe you
shouldn't be making the longer movie
sorry let's talk about excellent
campaign video blows you away gets you
to donate the campaign goes nowhere 31
days expire whatever the length you look
at it and it's this pressing them out
and you're like how is this possible
that will all be in the Outreach so if
you have a really fantastic crowdfunding
video and uh and it's you know pulling
at people's heartstrings the only reason
there's they're not contributing well
I'll say this number one is maybe that's
a fantastic pitch video by someone's
standards but not by the standards of
the audience that are actually there for
the movie so uh there's that piece but
if it really is like an exceptional
crowdfunding video I've never seen an
exceptional crowdfunding video no one
time I did actually one time on seeden
spark probably still the best
crowdfunding video I've ever seen in my
life and the campaign went nowhere and
that's because they did zero Outreach
and nobody saw it right so you can't
just make an excellent crowdfunding
video and put it on a website and hope
that somebody sees it it is your
responsibility on any platform to drive
traffic and you start with your friends
and family that's your first 20 or 30%
in why because strangers like to pick a
winner they need to see momentum and
they need to see inevitability of
success right so you can demonstrate the
inevitability of success by making a
kick-ass crowdfunding video the momentum
you have to generate from your community
first which is why it's a really good
idea to build a crowd so you're not just
going to your friends and family but
your your immediate Community is already
people who are like yeah I want to see
this thing right so that by the time you
launch your campaign you're not just
limited to your mom dad uncle and like a
couple of your brother's Banker friends
so that immediate crowd again was those
people that got involved with the
process of it when you launched let's
say your Twitter or your Instagram
whatever called to you most and saw your
whatever tweets about a similar
situation that you're going to do a
story about or yeah those are the people
okay absolutely and then Outreach is
what Outreach has many components um
Outreach has there's direct Outreach um
and that is everybody that you can reach
by email oh I have to start by saying
this so
um social media is not a means unto is
not a a means unto itself or an end unto
itself um social media is a tool for
getting people to do stuff generally
speaking the highest conversion rate to
watching a movie contributing to a
campaign will come from direct emails so
actually um think about it as is
concentric circles the outermost
concentric circle is all the people you
don't know that's most of the people
inside that is everyone you can reach
through social media and you can grow
that capacity right um but it's not
entirely reliable a lot of times it's
feed-based or it's algorithm based so
when you tweet something it's not
guaranteed that 100% of your followers
will see it when you post something on
Facebook God knows how they display it
to people like it's a that is a secret
hidden behind lock and key um even when
you pay for it so um social media is
good but thanks to the power of the
smartphone you can reach Everybody by
email and if they're really excited to
get your emails they will open them and
read them right so I never look at
social media as like once I get to
200,000 Facebook followers I'm done
because I've seen campaigns with 200,000
Facebook followers fail right getting
people to like you on Facebook only
proves that you can get people to like
you on Facebook Facebook right um if you
can get them to like you on Facebook can
you then get them to to sign up for a
mailing list because you're giving them
some sort of reason or incentive to do
so and then once you reach them in their
inbox will they click on the stuff that
you send them this is all easily
trackable through all of the tools that
are available to us now it doesn't take
a rocket scientist trust me because if I
can do it anybody can do it um so what's
really important is to be able to
increase your direct Outreach capacity
so um part of the pre-campaign buildup
IS to try to really grow your email
lists primarily and whether that's
because you're doing a ton of Outreach
through social media and then you're
getting people to sign up for your email
list um or it's because you're
partnering with people who themselves
have email lists organizations things
like that um so the first part of your
Outreach is direct how many people can
you reach in their inbox and what is the
work it will take to reach all of the
people you can conceivably reach in
their inboxes and I would include in
direct Outreach actually Facebook direct
messaging Twitter direct messaging you
have to be careful with that because if
you just copy and paste to everyone
number one Facebook will shut you down
and number two you're likely to kind of
insensitively send somebody something
that may not be appropriate like if
you're not paying attention you might
send your crowdfunding campaign to your
friend who's like I just lost my mom or
your friend who's like I have no money
or whatever um or that happen s to me
all the time I'll get sent a
crowdfunding campaign for a film that's
crowdfunding on another platform and
I'll be like bro do you even read things
um not that I don't contribute on other
platforms I'm just like did you but did
you consider that who I anyway um so uh
so it's important to be very sensitive
to who you're reaching and Gathering all
the materials it takes to reach out to
them so you want to like bring all of
the message tested language together the
images that seem to have really worked
with your audience the music that seems
to have really worked with your audience
the videos that have seemed to really
work with your audience and get the text
as concise as possible because when
people open emails they need to get to
the decision making Point quickly right
the emails that you wait to write until
2: in the morning always end up being
the like long ones of why I got into
film in the first place and to be honest
basically nobody but your mom cares
right so get to the most concise bullet
points of like why me why this why now
why you communicate that make sure that
every time you send an email it also
includes immediately sharable Twitter
and Facebook language that you have
precomposed so you can turn me from my
inbox to a social media evangelist with
two clicks let's face it most people are
reading those kinds of emails while
they're sitting on the toilet they got
one hand free they they're if you if you
can help them share stuff with two
clicks of a thumb you're going to get
them to share stuff right so your direct
Outreach is really about getting people
in their inboxes
and also turning them into amplifiers
right that's one phase of Outreach and
usually there's like three categories of
direct Outreach for personal Outreach
the first is uh the people you're
basically sure are going to contribute
to your campaign it's like immediate
friends and family um who will support
anything that you do you're going to
reach out to them well in advance of
launching your campaign you're going to
tell them about what you're up to you're
going to get them to commit to
contributing you're going to find out
how much they might be willing to
contribute so you have an idea of where
you stand on day one that's really
important um and if one of them says
like I'm in for $2,000 you're like great
can we run a matching campaign in the
second week of our campaign to see if we
can turn that 2,000 into 4,000 and
incentivize people to get involved in
the second week of the campaign so you
can keep up your
momentum so you're going to get a sense
through your direct Outreach of what
you're going to do on day one and you
know maybe there's some options and
opportunities in the second and third
week of your campaign for bringing those
larger contributors in a little later
um there's the second set of people who
you're like maybe with a personal email
they will get involved and you need to
really look at how long is that list and
you got to pull the resources of all of
your film making team how long is this
list um because if it's two or 300
emails you're not going to send them all
in one day if you need to send two or
300 more or less personalized emails
that's part of the work that you're
parsing out for yourself in the campaign
you're organizing I'm going to I'm going
to commit to sending 10 per day right um
giving yourself something that you can
stick to as opposed to something you're
going to procrastinate on until the last
week of your campaign then you're going
to send a bunch of desperate emails that
aren't very effective they're going to
be those long diet tribes horrible um
and then the third category is kind of
like everyone you've ever emailed ever
that's acing in your Gmail inbox and you
can create a um um like a MailChimp list
and just check in with people and make
sure they want to be subscribed to to it
and then you can kind of blast them a
couple times throughout the campaign
Come What May right that's a good way to
start your mailing list there um and
then any organizational Outreach so
anybody who's willing to put you in
their newsletter or send you out to
stuff you have to give them the
materials they need to succeed as well
the organizational part in the Outreach
is the most important part you need to
be prepared in advance with um not only
how you're doing all your direct
Outreach but how you're keeping your
social media feed fresh your Twitter
feed while you're crowdfunding can't now
devolve into only self-promotional
tweets you need to keep up about a 9:1
ratio and that means you still need to
be in the conversation the ideas around
your film maybe around film making or
around the topic of the film that you're
making um you know for dear white people
for example it's really easy you can get
into a lot of like interesting comedic
uh takes on race or social justice um
they have a sort of a clear conversation
they can get involved in um figuring out
what that is and making sure you're
still maintaining that takes a plan
right you have to have either somebody
who's doing it uh or somebody who's
researching it or you do a bunch of
research in advance and you say okay I
think these are the topics we're going
to really focus on each week these are
the audiences we're really going to try
to reach each week we're going to focus
a lot on Twitter because we know we can
reach our like young women interested in
social justice there but actually like
if we really want to get to like the
filmmaker crowd they're actually largely
on Instagram so we're going to do this
thing on Instagram for that audience and
then um there's the sort of uh like Baby
Boom generation who's very interested in
you know seeing versions of themselves
as children that they never got movies
that never got made when they were
children sort of like the sort of
nostalgic thing and they're more
reachable on Facebook right and so this
is going to be our campaign on Facebook
you've got to have a plan for your
social media to keep it fresh fresh keep
it interesting if you're tweeting the
same in week four that you were in
week one we are bored and probably have
unfollowed you right so you have to have
a plan for that as well um and your
updates that every crowdfunding uh
platform has a an update uh function
it's kind of like a Blog but let me be
clear people don't uh subscri don't
contribute let me be clear people don't
contribute to crowdfunding campaigns to
just like subscribe to blogs the point
of your updates is to show progress to
demonstrate further inevitability of
success to keep up the momentum um to
bring people deeper into your uh your
world and the content should be Visual
and sharable in exciting ways you have
to make your updates easily sharable
whether you're using click to tweet or
you're pre-composting sharable language
um all the time everything that you're
doing should increase the virality of
your campaign the sharability virality
is dumb because like you can't you can't
predict virality all you can do is try
to increase your chances to achieve
it I want to go back to something that
you said regarding figuring out what the
initial F that concentric Circle in the
very very core would be family and
friends what if that's not a high number
do you still launch a crowdfunding
campaign so the question is what do you
do if your immediate Community isn't
that large um and the answer is you
don't try to squeeze blood from a stone
so um you can use crowdfunding as a tool
to build your community if you do it
slowly and responsibly and you're
prepared to deliver on your promises at
each phase so um the cool thing that's
been happening in crowdfunding is uh the
use of staged financing and so on seed
and Spark for example you only open one
page for your film and you can do
successive crowdfunding campaigns inside
that same page and build your funders
and followers and a crew an audience in
a single place right um one of the best
ways we ever saw this used was a
filmmaker named Liam Brady who had been
at NYU Tish just head down making movies
becoming an aour right and it was time
for him to make his thesis film and he
looked up and the landscape had changed
and he was like wow I really want to
crowdfund this film um and I have a
couple of problems the first is my
community isn't that big right now
because I haven't been cultivating it um
and I'm a little bit sensitive about
going to my friends and family who have
kind of helped me fund other movies that
I made earlier um two uh I actually
don't have the script all the way
developed because it's dependent a
little bit on casting but I don't have
money to hire a casting director and how
do I really kind of kick it up the next
Notch and I need to do readings with
actors but that means I have to get
space and I have to you know and I
really need some materials to build
audiences and get the word out and kind
of glad hand a little bit so he decided
to run a $6,000 development campaign for
a film called fog City and he was going
to hire a casting director he was going
to print some marketing materials uh he
was going to uh do some uh uh like table
reads and make sure that he could pay
for a space and feed his actors imagine
that um and uh and then throw a party
also to give people a sense of the other
work that he's done to really like offer
something to the community to say here's
what I'm here to do I would really love
for you to join me um and he said about
this development campaign he ran a
60-day campaign which is a long time to
crowdfund um and he raised
$6,600 he actually he was funded within
30 days because it was a it was a very
good crowdfunding video it was a very
successful he was very dialed in in his
Outreach um and he does all this
work and he does you know the $6,600
campaign he develops the script just as
he promised he keeps the audience
updated along the way and as a result of
all of these things he was doing and
executing on the promises he made in the
first campaign people approached him
from his community and said I would like
to get involved in this film in a more
material way this film really matters to
me um and so he did the development he
needed he got it cast as he needed he
knew at that point how much the
production would cost him like when he
ran the development campaign he didn't
even know how much to ask for for the
full film because it wasn't developed
well enough it was going to it was cast
dependent and things like that so he got
a fully developed script he knew how
much the cast would cost him he could
price it out and because these people
had approached him and said I want to
get involved in a more meaningful way he
felt confident going out and ask asking
for the full production budget of the
film not the post- production just the
production budget of the film $ 35,000
$33,000 he does a $33,000 campaign less
than five months before the first
campaign but on the back of this wider
community of support that he had built
executing exactly proving himself
trustworthy along the way building a
tremendous amount of Social Capital
creating of evangelists of all the
people who had you know contributed to
this first smaller campaign um he raised
$35,000 in 30 days in this second
campaign um also because he learned a
lot about the way his community wanted
to be spoken to his second Pitch video
is quite a bit different it reached out
in a different way but he said very
clearly this is not for post- production
I'm going to crowdfund again for post so
he goes and he shoots the film and he
starts editing the film and N9 months
later um when he knows exactly what he
needs to get through the like full
Festival submission
post production music period um he does
another 30-day campaign for $6,000 this
time making an extraordinarily tongue
and cheek crowdfunding video because he
built up the film is a drama about a
veteran and a baseball team and it's
it's sort of dark and deep and beautiful
um but the pitch video was utterly
irreverent because at this point he had
built up such a rapport with his
audience that he knew how he could speak
to them without sort of fussing with the
tone of the film or the the gravitas of
the campaign raised $6,000 by himself in
his sleep only because he had done all
of this work in advance and that got him
to
$57,000 for a short film that was his
NYU thesis film which is now out you
know submitted to festivals so question
when he did his initial Outreach for the
6,000 Plus in the very beginning and
he'd had his head down he'd been busy
with classes what was the Outreach cuz
did he go on social media oh yeah no he
spent he spent two months three months
on social media in advance making sure
that everybody he knew knew that this
was coming down the pipeline nobody was
surprised they're like Liam launching a
crowdfunding campaign no everybody knew
this was coming right um the second
piece of it is uh a tremendous amount of
email Outreach reconnecting with people
he hadn't been connecting connecting
with he moved back to San Francisco from
New York during this time and like
reconnected with like the Film Society
community and like went to events and
met filmmakers in his community and
learned who he would need to outreach to
there there was a lot of like imperson
Outreach that he was doing in the months
in the advance in advance of his
campaign I see okay so it wasn't just
you know what this is the dollar amount
I need for the beginning and I'm going
to launch the Twitter now and I'm going
to do the Instagram he started it well
in advance he kept updated you can't
start your relationship with your
Audience by asking them for money that's
absurd on its face you have to start by
getting them really excited about what
you're going to offer them if only you
have the resources and that's a process
you know this isn't a a light switch you
can flip on it just isn't and I don't
feel sorry to say that to people it's
like the the people you see like Lou CK
and Ed Burns who are gloriously
benefiting from the direct relationship
they have With Their audience that's
something that they took the time energy
and intention to cultivate right long
before they you know were stars of stage
and scream
actually Ed Burns told me that it was
Ted Hope who sat him down and was like
dude if your career is in a slump you
need a Twitter
account that's so you know it it also
isn't necessarily true that um you know
your Fame will carry you or it's we just
have to get out of this universe of
somebody's going to hand it to me or
somebody's going to pick me no you have
to go and pick them you have to go and
pick your audience one by one and tell
them why they should join your journey
that's the work that's the
work Emily in one of your videos I think
you've said that raising money for the
movie is the easy part no no that's not
what I said getting people to see the
film that's the hard part people think
raising money is the hardest part it's
not getting anyone to see your film when
it's finished is way harder okay well
we've spoken to filmmakers who spent 3
years 5 years 10 years or more raising
money for their films how can
distribution be harder than
that uh je well okay so there's that's
Lo that's a loaded question right
because if you're going through
traditional
financing methods those are incredibly
dependent upon cast and director and the
lead investor and and then somebody gets
burned and they pull out and all that
stuff um at the $3 to5 million level
which is still something that
crowdfunding doesn't regularly achieve
um it's hard for a separate set of
reasons than um like that part of
financing is hard for sort of a separate
set of reasons the reason distribution
is harder is um that the you know the
powers that be that will reach down and
sort of offer you distribution only do
it to
04 of the films that are made every year
right so you have to do it yourself and
for the most part we have not been given
good information we don't have great
data out there to help us build smart
business models we're still learning
about all the tools that are available
to us there's a tremendous amount of
misinformation there's a lot of Bad
actors out there that will tell you that
if you pay them $10,000 they can help
you get the distribution deal that will
really help you um there's there are
Myriad difficulties built inside of
distribution but ultimately getting
enough people to watch your movie
um is is tremendously difficult and it
it takes a lot of time and and resources
particularly if you think you should be
making $5 million films that's a lot of
people buying movie tickets to pay that
money back right um and because audience
is built one person at a time so I
understand that uh seedan spark is
coming up on two years yeah so congrats
and I know you're have okay and I know
you're having a big party for that and
fairly
soon have any of the projects on seen
spark made more money on the
distribution side than they have on the
crowdfunding side um we don't know yet
uh it t this so the interesting thing
one of the reasons why we're in such a
tumultuous period is it takes a long
time to take a move movie from beginning
all the way to the end so the films that
crowdfunded the very first films that
crowdfunded with us many of them are
only just entering the festival circuit
kind of now because you know we have
these sort of Festival Seasons um and uh
very few of them have have come onto the
streaming platform yet um and the other
thing is like I don't think they're
going to make all their money back on
our streaming platform which is why
we're building distribution in 2015
we'll be Distributing out as well um
because I think our job as the platform
is to give filmmakers a chance to with a
crowd successful crowdfunding campaign
guarantee themselves some meaningful
distribution Beyond a single platform um
what we know is that when films are on
multiple particularly digital platforms
um when they're on multiple digital
platforms they do better on all
platforms right so being on a single
platform is not a good plan and we don't
we don't constrain them that way at all
it's totally not exclusive um I'm hoping
that in 2015 we will finally get to see
the sort of full circuit model play out
but many of our films were waiting to go
to festivals and in the meantime we're
trying to build into our process the
meaningful distribution deals that by
the time they do come to us they'll go
on our platform they'll go out to
various other platforms um and
opportunities and really be able to make
money I will say this um our original
idea was extraordinarily idealistic
they'll just crowdfund and then they'll
stream and they'll make all their money
back it's just it was never going to be
that simple right and this is why we've
um explored these other opportunities
for distribution um because you have to
meet their your audience where they want
to be we can't I think it's silly to
kind of try to force them force their
hand in a New Direction right now as
audiences are feeling this
terrible um kind of onslaught of
platforms and devices and all these
things and the good thing about having
waited is now you have a you know a
chomecast or an Amazon fire stick and
anything that's on your laptop is on
your TV you know sort of it it's sort of
amazing but just in a couple of years
whereas we maybe should have built for
you know Roku and apple and all these
things they just built a stick you plug
into your computer you can stream
anything that you're streaming right
onto your television you know so the
nice thing is the technology is making
it easier for all of us to be on all
devices and we should try to be on all
devices because some of your audience is
going to consume it on their mobile
phone get over it some of your audience
is going to want to consume it on their
TV and that's great and a lot of your
audience is going to be streaming it
curled up in their bed on their laptops
which maybe means you don't have to
shoot on 6K raw all the time I'm just
saying but
anyway we found this statement on the
seeden spark website if you add up the
cable bills the video streaming
subscriptions and all of the movie
tickets sold Americans spend one uh 120
billion which calculates to 39 $6 each
on video entertainment in 2012 and
somewhere between 80 to 90% of that
money went to the companies that
delivered the content not to the actual
artists that created those films correct
where do you see the future of film
making and distribution in the next 5 to
10 years that being said so um we're
already seeing it be massively
disintermediated right um which means
you don't need three or four Gatekeepers
in between you and your audience anymore
um thanks to this thing right you can
reach your audience directly it has
never been true before that the tools
that Beyonce and the president of the
United States use to reach Their
audience you also have in your pocket
like I don't think people still have
fully comprehended the power in that
alone that the authoring tools that are
available to the most famous most
prestigious and wealthiest are also
available to you and me right um which
is not to say you are not yourself
extraordinarily prestigious um I think
uh the the disintermediation is
tremendous I also think it will become
way more decentralized so because these
tools are available look I just spent um
35 days I went to 26 cities and I met
people in Memphis and Houston and South
Jordan Utah and Bellingham Washington
and um there are filmmakers in all of
these places who don't want to
move have no interest of paying the
rents that we pay in Los Angeles or that
we pay in New York or even honestly that
you pay in Austin Texas um and they want
to make films and they could make a
really good living for themselves at
$60,000 a year right so if your ambition
is not to become rich and famous with
film making but to make the work that's
really meaningful to you and get it to
an audience to whom it is also really
meaning
I believe that pretty soon we will see
people we will actually see the rise of
a creative middle class in the film
industry that is not in New York and LA
because it's too flipp and expensive to
live there but actually you know if you
could make uh five films a year one of
which is yours four of which are ones
that you're working on your friends and
they're 100 or
$120,000 budgets some are bigger some
are smaller um you know you keep
yourself sort of furiously
uh dedicated to making the most
excellent versions of the things you
rely on your peers to make you better
you use every technology available to
you to make it inexpensively and to
connect directly with the audiences to
whom it matters along the way I think we
will see filmmakers making a sustainable
living and again I don't mean getting
rich and famous I do mean maybe making
enough money to feed their families and
hopefully make little artist babies and
make you know more empathic people
people in the world um yeah so I
think it's it's the way that everything
is going right much more decentralized
um much more disintermediated I think
there's some big big question marks out
there that are a little scary right so
um you know we have this question out
there about net neutrality and of course
net neutrality would be very bad for a
company like C the lack of net
neutrality would be very bad for a
company like seed and Spark um but you
know Google is out there laying fiber
all over the world um and they might
effectively create a two tier internet
if their fiber is way faster than um the
stuff that's currently available to us
through our crappy cable companies right
and if they effectively create a
two-tier
internet just out of like
convenience um that's a we have to hope
that they really meant it when they said
don't be evil right that's one piece of
it and um I think there are some
corporations out there that are creating
conglomerates that are putting a lot of
pressure on um the way that the
distribution business Can Build and Grow
I think lack of data is very damaging to
us right now um if
I could leave behind a legacy um that I
would be most proud of it would be in
sort of spearheading or joining or or
encouraging the effort to get companies
like Netflix to release um the
viewership data to the filmmakers so the
filmmakers had any hope of building
better business models based on the data
that Netflix is collecting um I think
it's at this point if your user data is
your only competitive Advantage um you
better think about what you're offering
to people um so I think it's really
really essential for us to as filmmakers
and artists demand that we get the most
most data we can get so we can learn
about the audiences how they view what
they view what it means to them um where
they're viewing things to whatever
extent we can so that we can build
smarter business models I think if we um
continue to sort of beat our head
against the wall of like I'm going to
make a movie for three million with
stars in it and I'm going to take it to
a big festival and whatever um we'll
have a lot of really disappointed
disenfranchised artists cuz a few people
will get to do that that and um you know
the rest of the folks who are trying to
do that will sort of Fall by the wayside
I think you have to we we have to be
highly educated in the tools that are
available to us to dominate our
independent careers they are available
those tools are available we now have to
demand the data um I think that you know
is a is an essential component of it um
and provided we don't have sort of a
tyrant to your internet or we don't lose
net neutrality altogether I think we can
rely on the distribution getting you
know faster cheaper better all the time
because that's what the audience demands
ultimately you know so this middle class
artist how do you envision them being
paid from if they're going direct to the
consumer in this theoretical 5 to 10
year landscape how do you see them well
if they can go direct to Consumer um I
think there is a proliferation now of
platform forms who are sharing the Lion
Share of the revenue directly with the
filmmaker we're 8020 filmmakers keep 80
we keep
20 um and we're not the only one like
that um I I think it comes from um yeah
disintermediating the distribution funds
right so not having quite so many people
in between you and the money that you're
audience is spending to see your stuff
um I think it comes from working on your
friends project
I think I think it's a I think it's an
amalgam of I work on my friends movies
and everybody gets paid some piece of it
and I make backend on those films and I
make back end on my films because
there's back end to be made because
we're doing this in a more
disintermediated environment um I think
it probably comes from Brand patronage I
think brands are really waking up to the
fact that it's not about branded content
it is about associating your brand with
the content that audience are really
excited about this is another
opportunity that's open up totally
opened up to you that you don't have if
you don't have the direct relationship
to your audience if you have a direct
relationship with an audience that a
brand is interested in they will pay you
money so that you talk favorably about
that brand to your audience um and
they're willing to do it in more and
more creative ways so and we've proven
this I mean bright ideas magazine
started because we convinced a brand
that we had access to an audience that
they wanted to assoc with really really
cool content that they didn't have any
say over that we could um associate
their name with brands are really
looking for ways to be prestigious and
meaningful this is the other thing is
like people think that brand is a bad
word or that brands are sort of
inherently selling out no in fact there
are lots of Brands out there that really
want to be a part of this movement to
empower artists to make really cool
important meaningful
stuff we once had a film maker tell us
that a distributor literally told them
if you want your money you're going to
have to sue us and I know who this
distributor is he was forced to hire a
lawyer to take them to court so what are
your feelings on the current state of
distribution for
filmmakers you know this is the inherent
problem of feeling like you have to hand
your film to somebody else to distribute
it is they then have the control over
everything between your film and the
audience and all the money that comes
back in the other direction um I
don't I know so many examples of the
distribution deal gone wrong it's really
disheartening um and it is a uh I think
further impetus to um taking control of
building audiences and reaching
audiences into your own hands
um I can use Justin Simeon as an example
again so good was he at reaching his
audience talking to them building them
cultivating them exciting them that he
got hired by the company that
distributed his film to make all of this
content to keep them excited in between
when the film got picked up after
Sundance and when it was released in
October right so he got to make more
stuff right that he loved um and he was
the best person to speak to his a
audience and that that created a
relationship of sort of trust and
necessity in a distributor relationship
now I don't know all the particulars
like I maybe they would
say it wasn't all Wine and Roses but it
certainly looks like it from the outside
um I think it's uh it is essential to
understand that you actually have a
responsibility to make your IP valuable
so that the Distributors are coming to
you and then you get to say I want that
one and not that one and these are the
terms of my deal because you're the one
who's really coming with a relationship
to the audience um something that I
think because we get so excited when
somebody wants to pick our movie um do
your research don't ever work with a
company that you haven't fully vetted no
matter how much they're breathing down
your neck and saying this deal expires
in 24 hours it's like well then you
don't get the movie because I need to
find out from the people who worked with
you how it was I guarantee you this
wasn't the first person uh who worked
with this distributor who had a sort of
like
unseemly uh relationship you know had
was was treated poorly so I think it's
really important and I actually see this
I'm really excited in my film making
Community all the time somebody will
post on Facebook like who's worked with
gravitas what did you think and I'll
write and I'll be like I love them I
think Mia Bruno is one of the smartest
people I've met recently and I really
like the way that she works on things um
or you know
hey I'm having this problem with this
company has anybody else had this
problem and how do you deal with it so I
think this is when you really have to
rely on your community but you you just
can't escape doing your research you
know I'm not saying that it was this
guy's fault or anything it's just really
important to make sure you know to vet
anybody that you work with don't take
the first deal that comes just cuz it's
the first deal make sure that it's the
right deal so due diligence research on
on the net find out and also ask other
people post on you know maybe if you
don't want to go out there publicly with
the name then direct message someone
yeah you send it you I I get these
emails as well from Friends hey does
anybody know anybody here what did you
think of them how what was it like
working with them what's been your
experience you know um uh Dylan marchet
from uh what is now amplify uh is one of
those people that everybody's like I
love him you know and and that's really
important that kind of reputation is
really important and the good ones have
it and the bad ones don't it's that
simple right so how much time should
someone research I mean that don't just
take like a couple days and go you know
I don't see anything here looks good
take your time with it reach out to
filmmakers who've had their films
distributed through those Distributors
and get a hold of them and don't say yes
until you've actually spoken to one of
them about your experience you know I
mean yeah you can get on the internet
and see if anybody's ranted but you
might also you know people rant about
look take Yelp your favorite restaurant
has 25 terrible Yelp reviews okay so you
know not everybody's experience is your
is your own experience I I think it's
important to talk to at least a couple
of people um and really vet your
Distributors you know they're they're
also getting a good deal by getting your
film right so you can you can also take
the time to make sure it's really smart
and just don't let people pressure you
into taking stuff trust your gut don't
work with people who make your skin
crawl that's important important
seriously just don't work with people
who make your skin
crawl